el mástil principal de un bote de pesca
está sostenido por una cuerda tensa
amarrada de la parte superior del mástil
a la cubierta si el más que él tiene 20
pies de altura y la cuerda está amarrada
a la cubierta a 15 pies de la base del
mástil cuál es la longitud de la cuerda
ok vamos a hacer un dibujo para
asegurarnos de entender todo lo que está
sucediendo aquí esto de aquí va a ser la
cubierta del barco voy a acabar de
dibujar el barco va a ser más o menos
algo así por aquí si quieres ponemos
algunas olas aquí bueno las voy a poner
más arriba
aquí tenemos unas olas sale
ahí va ok y lo importante es que nos dan
el mástil el mástil es uno de los palos
que sostienen las velas del barco
entonces lo voy a dibujar por acá ahí
tenemos el mástil algo de este estilo
del cual nos dan la longitud nos dicen
que que mide 20 pies de altura aquí le
voy a poner 20 pies 20 pies salen y nos
dicen que hay una cuerda que está
amarrada de la parte superior a la
cubierta a 15 pies de la base del mástil
entonces si la cuerda es no se ver de la
cuerda quedaría amarrada por un lado acá
y por otro lado más o menos por acá de
tal forma que esto que estoy acá mida 15
15 pies déjame dibujar la cuerda con
otro color la voy a poner en color azul
muy bien entonces estoy acá sería la
cuerda estoy aquí es el dibujo y justo
lo que nos piden es determinar la
longitud de la cuerda vamos a ver qué
sucede en este dibujo en este dibujo hay
algunas cosas especiales pasando aquí
tenemos un triángulo y no es cualquier
triángulo
esto es la cubierta y este es un mástil
del barco este es horizontal esta es
vertical y por lo tanto este ángulo de
acá es de 90 grados y es un ángulo recto
y entonces tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo y en los triángulos
rectángulos podemos conocer la longitud
del tercer lado conociendo la longitud
de los otros dos a partir del teorema de
pitágoras le voy a poner por acá teorema
teorema
de de pitágoras
y gracias muy bien y tag horas lo que
nos dice el teorema de pitágoras es algo
muy sencillo nos dice que si tomamos la
longitud del lado más grande que se
llama la hipotenusa del triángulo la voy
a señalar estoy acá es la hipotenusa
hipotenusa
y esa longitud la elevamos al cuadrado
entonces es lo mismo que sumar los
cuadrados de los dos lados más cortos
que se llaman catetos entonces vamos a
ver qué nos dice el teorema de pitágoras
en este caso básicamente nos dice que si
elevamos 20 al cuadrado lo voy a poner
por acá 20 al cuadrado y a eso le
sumamos 15 al cuadrado le sumamos 15 al
cuadrado
15 al cuadrado entonces eso es igual a
la longitud de la hipotenusa pero eso
justo es la longitud de la cuerda déjame
ponerle c porque es una cuerda le voy a
ponerse entonces es esto de esta
longitud que va hacia acá y hacia acá
vale entonces tenemos que 20 al cuadrado
más 15 al cuadrado es igual a c elevado
al cuadrado y a partir de aquí podemos
desarrollar 20 al cuadrado es igual a
400 le voy a poner aquí 415 al cuadrado
es 225 200 b voy a ponerlo más para acá
220 5 y eso es igual a sea al cuadrado
ac al cuadrado 400 más 225 es igual a
625 625 y entonces 625 es igual es igual
a c elevado al cuadrado así que para
obtenerse tenemos que sacar raíz de
ambos lados aquí tenemos que sacar raíz
acá también tenemos que sacar raíz y
obtenemos que c es igual
a la raíz de 625 a la raíz positiva
porque necesitamos una longitud positiva
vale a las longitudes son positivas y
bueno para sacar la raíz de 625 podemos
ver que 20 al cuadrado es más chiquito
es 430 al cuadrado es 900 se pasa así
que debería ser como la mitad como 25 y
si si verifican las cuentas 25 al
cuadrado es 625 entonces c es igual a 20
5 de esta forma la longitud de la cuerda
es 25 es de 25 pies